[Music]  Emmie peas will quiz the Commission on  its plan to offer clean energy to all  Europeans the aim of the energy union is  to ensure affordable climate friendly  energy in Europe conventional pesticides  can be dangerous for the environment and  consumers lower-risk biopesticides exist  but any Peas want an extension of the  list of authorized alternatives which  strategy should Europe choose in the  Arctic climate change will enable better  access to natural resources and open new  shipping routes but Emmie peas are  concerned about the strength and  presence of the Russian military  pharmaceutical industry is one of the  most competitive in Europe but  affordability of drugs remained the  problem for citizens and it of the  Health Committee will examine access to  medicines and competitiveness of generic  and biomedicine